foreign
is there Dwayne how can we help yes sir
I have a 200 000 term uh for 20 years
it's got about 19 years left I'm coming
up off another one that's why I got this
other one so overlap it
um but because I'm just coming up off
the first one I'm wondering maybe I
should get a whole life and I'm
listening to what you and I think Suz
I'm on everyone said hey whole life is
bad but every time I talk to the mutual
mess and these other they are convincing
me no it's a solid you won't lose money
and so I wanted to call directly and
find out what am I losing when I start
talking to them that it seems like I'm
pretty firm on what I'm listening to
what you guys are saying is there
something I'm missing in Translation
well Dwayne here's a simple way to think
about it what would they stand to gain
by persuading you to get whole life
versus term life from them
I'm sure some kind of financial gain
there we go the commissions on whole
life are astronomical and there's a good
reason your term life policy costs about
five percent of the cost of an
equivalent whole life policy and so when
you're paying you know 15 20 30 bucks a
month for that Term Policy versus 600
well there's a lot more wiggle room for
them to steal your commissions under the
guise of well you're going to build this
cash value policy and you're going to
invest it over a long period of time
you're going to make so much money
Dwayne don't invest in the market invest
with me in this insurance policy do you
see what they're doing there
yeah yeah but it it does sound like
again this is when I'm talking to him I
get overwhelmed the numbers and
everything and when they get done
they say hey look see you put this money
in which to me is a huge amount of money
per month it is that you could be
investing yourself into much more uh
solid Investments that have a much
better track record
but what they do well here's I'm
guessing here's what they did they did
some real fancy math that was real
complicated to where they're like well
Dwayne you just got to trust me man this
is this will work yeah yeah I I have a
little I'm gonna just throw this let's
get out of the money you started the
call by saying that you agreed with us
on whole life you've you've listened to
this and you have an opinion on this
yourself true or false
yes when I listened I said hey that
sounds right because it felt crazy the
money they're asking for right so hold
on so don't afford that I know so stop
so remember why you feel that way
we've made a case
and we didn't convince you
you convinced you
and so you walk away going that's nuts
it's crazy to put all that money in
there it doesn't make any sense you got
to remember that
do you trust yourself do you trust your
common sense do you trust that opinion
that you came to before you ever walked
in to talk with these guys typically
obviously I do well I know so no no no
but what happens is you sit down and
somebody makes a really compelling case
and they've got this thing down pat then
what they're saying makes sense too but
then you go it doesn't make sense but
now they're making it sound like it
makes sense you just gotta say I don't
think it makes sense I know it doesn't
make sense here's why I think it's crazy
and then move on
well they're The Fear Factor too that
after 20 years what's going to be the
cost of another term I'm 50.
George can tell you that so the idea is
that not you don't have insurance for
your whole life the idea is that you
follow the Ramsay plan you pay off your
house in 15 years if you do our plan
with a 15-year fixed rate mortgage and
20 years later you've got a huge pile of
money in your investment accounts and
then you become what we call
self-insured where you don't need that
money anymore because you have more than
that in your investment account and you
only need it if someone relies on your
income like a spouse and George real
quick just break that down the money
that you would invested a whole life and
the return on that versus the money you
would put in the 401K the Stock Program
I mean excuse me mutual fund program
based on the growth of the whole nine
yards that we you know the return on
that is Big Time different break it down
quickly yeah so if you take the
difference from that whole life premium
with your term premium take the
difference that you would have paid and
you pop that onto our investment
calculator ramseysolutions.com
and let's say you get an average return
even eight to ten percent over 30 years
see what that would turn into Yeah by
doing it on your own you don't need them
because all they're doing is taking most
of that in commissions for the first
bunch of years and eventually maybe
you'll get a crappy return so avoid this
at all costs and run why even talking to
these people go talk to our friends at
Xander they're not going to sell you
this whole life crap and stop even
entertaining these fools yeah it's
absolutely right good advice you got me
riled up well I love boy I love it boy
boy loving you I lead a sound life that
that's what gets me riled up Ken but
it's fine well